chuck schumer is doing everything in his
power to abolish the filibuster which
presently is preventing him from passing
joe biden's most radical policy
proposals which includes a federal
takeover of the election process
but the filibuster is a long-standing
and distinguishing feature of the united
states senate that its defenders
consider to be essential to the
functioning and integrity of our
democratic republic so yesterday
republican senator tom cotton took to
the floor of the senate to make the case
for keeping the filibuster
right now we are on the precipice of a
constitutional crisis
we're about to step into the abyss the
nuclear option is being pushed largely
by the radioactive rhetoric of a small
band of radicals
who hold in their hands the political
fortunes of the president the senate is
not a majoritarian body
the bottom line is very simple
the ideologues in the senate
want to turn the founding fathers
what the founding fathers called the
cooling saucer of democracy into a
rubber stamp of dictatorship
they will make this country into a
banana republic it will be
a doomsday for democracy if we do those
are powerful words
but they're not mine
every word of my speech today
was originally spoken
by our esteemed colleague
the senior senator from new york
uh
very awkward if you are the senate
majority leader
chuck schumer
yikes really great troll from tom cotton
this is what happens when you stick
around national politics
for decades as have chuck schumer and
joe biden joe biden who made similarly
impassioned defenses of the filibuster
during the bush years
sometimes your old impassioned
sanctimonious please
contradict your new
impassioned sanctimonious please
and you are revealed to be nothing more
mr schumer than a power hungry carnival
barker i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from sir soplow who
says that fbi official jill sanborn the
one who was testifying and got grilled
by ted cruz over january 6th jill
sanborn probably told her parents i
cannot answer that when they asked if
she ate the cookies while holding the
cookie jar jill
jill did you are you did you have any
cookies no i cannot answer that it would
be a violation of norms if i answered
that it would be completely not jill
your hand is in the cookie jar jill did
you did the feds have anything to do
with january 6th i cannot i'm sorry i
cannot answer that jill you're wearing a
horn hat you are your face is painted
red and blue you're screaming to go in
like i'm sorry
would be a violation of norms
to answer that you've got to cover your
tracks if you're a fed who's trying to
set up the right to look like a bunch of
terrorists
and when you want to cover your tracks
when you want to keep your information
private you got to check out expressvpn
did you know that your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit
every single one even the ones you don't
want people to know about even the ones
that could get you in trouble even the
ones you look at on that incognito you
know what i'm talking about
dailywire.com you know politically
incorrect kind of stuff well what's
worse
they can sell this information to ad
companies and tech giants who will use
your data to target you expressvpn puts
a stop to this it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that your online
activity can't be seen by anyone i use
expressvpn on all of my devices i love
it i don't go online without having
expressvpn on my computer on my phone
you can use it even on routers everyone
who shares your wi-fi can still be
protected even if they don't have
express vpn i love it seriously if you
haven't recognized the threat post to
your privacy and way of life by the big
tech companies right now then i don't
know how to help you get expressvpn okay
if you believe your online activity is
your business secure it right now
expressvpn.com knowles use that link exp
or essvpn.com
knowles get an extra three months for
free expressvpn.com
knowles chuck schumer
got caught
dead to rights
so insincere and so disingenuous on the
filibuster
17 years ago he says
it's a threat to our democracy it'll
turn us into a banana republic if we get
rid of the filibuster today he says it's
a threat to our democracy it'll turn us
into a banana republic if we don't get
rid of the filibuster he just wants
power during the bush years it served
his power interests to keep the
filibuster today
it
will harm his power interests to get rid
of to to keep the filibuster
and so
he's trying to get rid of it he even
admitted this he said the quiet part out
loud on msnbc you don't need to take my
word for it you don't need to try to
discern the private secret thoughts in
chuck schumer's mind he went on tv and
he said look we got to get rid of the
filibuster because otherwise we're going
to lose our elections
well we are working there are constant
meetings and not just among the few
senators but just about every senator
every single one of the 50 is talking
individually to joe manchin to kirsten
cinema and they're saying things like
i'll lose my election if the legislature
is allowed to do this in my state we'll
lose our majority
i'll lose my election we'll lose our
majority can't have that so we the feds
the congress need to take over
the election system
from the states and local governments
where it's been for all of american
history we got to take that over right
now so that we can permanently ensconce
ourselves in power that's what he's
saying i'm trying to think of the most
charitable read i can
of what schumer is saying i guess the
most charitable read is this
in 2020
the
democrat election officials changed a
lot of the election rules and they got
rid of a lot of the safeguards and they
implemented things such as unsolicited
widespread mail-in ballots such as very
very early voting such as ballot drop
boxes they got rid of a lot of the poll
watchers to ensure election integrity
they did their best to suppress voter id
laws so they changed the election rules
right before the election
now republicans
are trying to re-implement some of those
election integrity measures they're not
even doing a great job of
re-implementing all of them the same
measures we had in place two years ago
but they're trying to bring some of them
back so that it's not just a complete
joke when we go to vote
and the democrats are saying this is
voter suppression
you're suppressing all of my voters who
can't prove that they're eligible voters
who
don't request mail-in ballots who don't
want to show up to the polls and many of
whom probably died decades ago
so this is voter suppression and that's
why we need to go and take over the
elections to to defend the little guy
that the republicans are going after but
that's that's not even what they're
saying
chuck schumer is not
saying that his colleagues come to him
and say oh my poor constituents are
having their right to vote taken away
and we must not no they're they're
speaking purely from their own self
narrow political interest i'm going to
lose my race
we the democrats are going to lose our
majority because our poll numbers are in
the gutter because people hate what
we're doing because we have failed on
every single front on the economy on
national security on
civil liberties uh even on kovid which
was the one area that they were in the
in the clear on now they're they're
below water on that as well on
immigration on
drugs on
education on the list goes on and on and
on so we've failed on everything the
people hate our guts our approval
ratings are very very low so we've got
to take over the elections and seize
power otherwise we're going to lose our
seats that's what it's about that's the
entire battle right now
over the filibuster
it's just about
power
now speaking of power politics there's
some power politics going on on the
right as well
donald trump
the front runner for the 2024 race the
last republican president
is taking a shot
at another serious 2024 contender ron
desantis without using desantis name
trump just came out and called ron
desantis gutless
for refusing to reveal whether or not
he's taken the third or fourth fouchy
algae
do you reconsider your push for it or
what's your view now on the vaccine in
general well i've taken it i've had the
booster
many politicians i watched a couple of
politicians be interviewed
and one of the questions was did you get
the booster because they had the vaccine
and they oh they're answering it like in
other words the answer is yes but they
don't want to say it
because they're gutless you got to say
it
whether you had it or not say it
but the fact is that i think the vaccine
has saved tens of millions of people
throughout the world
i have had absolutely no side effects
i've had it like other people have had
it nothing special
2024 has already started
that's the first takeaway donald trump
who has intimated that he's interested
in running again
is now taking shots
at his top rivals the 2024 republican
presidential primary has
already started
but i'm not sure i agree with his
advice here
i i understand why he is saying this why
he's saying that people need to
publicly come out and and tell everyone
whether or not they've had the vaccine
or the boosters but i don't think it's
good advice i think it's very bad advice
we're living in a biomedical security
state right now we are now living in a
place where you can be deprived
privileges and rights that you once had
based on whether or not you've taken
this experimental drug to possibly
not even prevent you from getting the
cough but from possibly mitigating some
of the symptoms of the cough
that doesn't seem like a wise idea to go
out and tell everyone whether or not
you've had it because
if whether you've had the vaccine or
you're never going to get the vaccine or
you're just waiting until there are more
data on it or something like that
when you
offer that information up you are giving
the ruling class more power
don't forget joe biden didn't institute
his osha mandate until after most
americans had received some of the
vaccine because he knew if he had
mandated it when only 10 of americans
had received any of the vaccine
it wouldn't have worked he wouldn't have
had the political capital to do it but
when he knew or when he strongly
suspected that most americans had some
of it then he had more political capital
so i think it's a really bad idea to
give the ruling class more of this
knowledge because the knowledge is power
as a as a personal matter for instance
if you come out and you say i hate the
vaccine i'm not taking this thing i
don't trust it i don't trust fauci i
don't trust any of these people i don't
trust the pharmaceutical companies in
the last couple of years so i'm never
taking that vaccine
well it's going to be very awkward
if you end up in a situation
a restaurant an airplane some other
situation where you were supposed to
have had the vaccine that opens you up
to a lot of liability to a lot of
vulnerability or vice versa if you took
the vaccine but you don't think it
should be mandated if you come out and
say i took it then you're putting
americans who don't want to take it in a
very bad spot so i think that's but but
trump is in this very difficult
political spot because he's the man
responsible for the vaccines so he's got
to push it even though his base is very
skeptical of them
one thing i am not skeptical of is this
plain fact that you can save a lot of
money on your mortgage right now when
you talk to american financing low
mortgage rates are still available but
they won't be around for much longer so
it's important to grab one while you can
only takes 10 minutes to get started
when you call american financing which
is america's home for home loans you'll
get a free mortgage review from a salary
based mortgage consultant you can learn
about options before moving forward
there's no pressure there's no
obligation there's no upfront or hidden
fees they're not like that instead
they take the time to get to know you
first so they can design a custom loan
that saves you up to a thousand dollars
a month plus tens of thousands of
dollars in the long term
so why not take the time to learn more
you could skip two mortgage payments and
may close in as fast as 10 days call
800-685-5696 that is 800-685-5696
or visit americanfinancing.net nmls
182-334-nmls consumeraccess.org
do not wait head on over there right now
save some money be financially
responsible american financing america's
home for home loans
donald trump is an extremely talented
politician the first time he ever ran
for office first time he ever
really officially ran for office he won
the most powerful position in the world
well other than dr fauci i guess i guess
the most powerful position in the world
now is running the national institutes
of allergy and infectious diseases but
right below that is president of the
united states and trump won it the first
time
he knows a lot about show business
he knows a lot about presenting himself
but he's in a really tough spot
because the first
big issue that trump could really get
rolled on is covid
policy trump allowed dr fauci to have
the microphone
trump allowed i think i'm not even
knocking him for it he was in
i think basically an impossible
situation
but nevertheless trump allowed fauci to
keep talking to elevate his stature
trump
pushed operation warp speed
trump so he's got to own the vaccines he
can't totally back away from what has
happened in the last couple years under
covid but unfortunately all those things
vouching to the vaccine policy to to all
of the coveted policy have been deeply
deeply unpopular with trump's base
so while i still think that trump is
clear far and away the front runner for
2024 if he wants it
this is the first issue where you might
see
some of the trump base moving toward
another candidate
who is that candidate well in this case
trump clearly thinks that desantis is
the big threat
the republican party is changing
trump i think was one of the big causes
for that change but it is changing and
even the more establishment politicians
are showing that kevin mccarthy who is
the republican leader in the house of
representatives just did an interview
with breitbart
mccarthy was asked about the chamber of
commerce the chamber of commerce is just
a big business organization
that
had dominated gop politics for
decades and is one of the big reasons
why the gop seemed always to just flack
for big corporations and try to cut
corporate taxes and seemed to be on the
side of billionaires
rather than say the ordinary working
people or small businesses so kevin
mccarthy asked about the chamber of
commerce he says yeah they're out of the
gop tent they're not coming back
one of the things that happened in the
wake of the january 6
everything that happened earlier this
year is that a bunch of companies and
special interests etc they cut off the
republican party i'd argue maybe this is
a good thing right like the chamber of
commerce they took a hike right like all
these special interests out there uh big
companies etc after virginia and new
jersey they all started to try to come
back in right like i think you came out
and said you know what no not you're not
welcome here right like we're the party
of the people uh
do special interests have a place in the
republican party look the thing i see
from a standpoint
the chamber left the party a long time
ago in the last election the chamber
supported democrats the chamber gave a
higher score
to democrats who were voting for this
policy because they signed some letter
and voted opposite of what the letter
said
then kevin brady who was chair of ways
and means and brought us the tax cuts i
just assume
they have as much influence as the
future as they do now not
and
our responsibility is the american
public and that's who's going to drive
it
does kevin mccarthy watch my show
i you know i hate to say i told you so
it pains me it's very very very
difficult
just yesterday on the show
i said that the future of the republican
party was not going to be with the
chamber of commerce the future of the
republican party was elsewhere and
republican politicians who wanted to be
on the right side of these things needed
to get with the program that the ones
who were going to be really prominent
2022 2024 and beyond we're going to be
the ones that moved away
from that chamber of commerce
kind of talking point list
and then you get one of the most
establishment politicians in washington
dc
kevin mccarthy to come out and say the
exact same thing i'm not saying it's
because he watches my show though i
don't know maybe
but certainly it is the case
that he is
proving my point
kevin mccarthy is a very good politician
you might not like him you might think
he's a little too moderate he's in a
leadership position in the house which
means in a way he kind of has to be more
moderate he can't be the most far-right
fire brand
but he is moving in the right direction
why is this because prominent
politicians
tend to be
very good politicians
meaning they know how to do politics
meaning they see which way the wind is
blowing
that you don't get to that position
generally without
having a decent political sense
and mccarthy knows where the future of
the party is
the future of the party is not going to
be flacking for billionaires who by and
large hate our guts
the future of the party is not going to
be technocratic egghead idiocy it's like
well you know
regardless of what real families are
struggling with now we just need to push
gdp a little bit higher once the gdp
goes up actually you see on the
spreadsheet we're all a lot richer and
better off yeah i know they're transing
your kids and i know that the life
expectancy is decreasing because people
are killing themselves and on drugs and
with with guns and ropes because they
they hate their lives so much but look
at the gdp and look at the profits of
the billionaires it that's not going to
work that's not going to convince
anybody
well i know that the majority of
americans hate immigration legal and
illegal immigration they want to
drastically reduce both but we heard
from it actually it increases the gdp a
little bit and it reduces the wages for
that yeah it's not that's not going to
work okay that's not going to work even
kevin mccarthy gets it
this is the future if you don't
understand that right now and you're a
conservative politician get on board
because you're going to get left behind
if you don't get on board talk about the
future of the american right the young
americas foundation uncovered an
incredible story
yesterday
yaf posted an article about a midwestern
elementary school
that is permitting the satanic temple
to host
satan club after school for the kids
jane adams elementary in illinois is
hosting multiple events
sponsored by the satanic temple
that it would be bad enough if they were
hosting their own events at the school
say after school hours but the events
are targeted at kids the event flyer
includes a permission slip for parents
to sign and says hey kids let's have fun
at after school satan club
now
the school
i had to issue a statement about this
yaf reached out to them
they said yes the satan club flyers are
posted around the elementary school
building
but they added religiously affiliated
groups are among those allowed to rent
our facilities for a fee
somewhere out there
somewhere out there in the recesses of
the squish
republican right of the the most tired
confused talking points dated
conservative movement types
there are people who will say
this is a wonderful thing
this is a blessing of liberty
look the satanic temple i might not
agree with them
but the satanists have just as much of a
right as the methodists or the jews to
use
the school the elementary school for
their meetings
they
by golly would you tell presbyterians
they can't host their meetings would you
tell muslims they can't host their
meetings well then you can't say that to
the satanists either this country
was built on religious freedom
and pluralism
my goodness if we tell the satanists
that they can't recruit
10 year olds and younger for their
occult rituals
why the founding fathers would roll in
their graves
if this sort of thing occurred
during the era of the founding or
earlier in american history
all of those men the founding fathers
the earlier men who built our country
would currently be gathering kindling to
burn these people at the stake
okay i'm not suggesting we burn the
satanists at the stake necessarily but i
am suggesting that older generations of
americans would have the same
generations of americans that we pretend
in our insane revisionist history
were these
totally wide open-minded pluralistic
people
who considered
satanic meetings at the elementary
school as american as apple pie not at
all buster not even close
this is a complete rewriting of american
history a complete rewriting of the
american understanding of religious
freedom and pluralism
it is a philosophical misunderstanding
based on this idea that in america in a
liberal democracy such as america we
cannot tell people what is right or
wrong
no we just have to accept every single
idea and remain perfectly neutral
but
that's not possible it's not possible
not only do we need to talk about what
is right and wrong what's good and bad
what is the common good not only do we
do we need to talk about not only should
we talk about that we need to talk about
that it is inevitable it has to happen
especially at elementary schools the
elementary school is already doing this
i promise you this elementary school has
lessons about how racism is bad
racism is bad i promise you
in probably every grade maybe every
class
do they need to remain neutral on racism
well we also need to represent the other
side is racism
good
i guarantee you they have
lessons about how
i don't know probably they have lessons
about how transgenderism is really good
and you can't oppose it are they going
to remain neutral no they can't because
if you teach one thing you can't teach
it's opposite you've got to talk about
good and bad and you've got to not only
talk about it you need to enforce a
conception of the common good it is
inevitable if we don't do it
the other side will
there's no neutrality
ben is going to be talking today
about some really bad things namely
everything joe biden has done as
president how he's a terrible president
and seven in 10 americans know it we
will be right back with a lot more
the satanist after school club
at this elementary school in illinois
where these creepy satan worshiping
adults go in to recruit kids
got me thinking
about all of the debates you hear about
in politics today
we've been told for a long time that the
big battle in the country is the left
versus the right
or the big battle in the country is the
republicans versus the democrats
or the
the big battle in the country is
i don't know freedom versus
socialism or the big battle in the
country is no michael it's not that it's
nationalism versus globalism
no it's
it's good versus evil
that's always what the political battle
is
and it rep
expresses itself in different ways so
yes you can have a battle over socialism
and you should be against socialism not
for social you have a battle over
whatever globalism
but ultimately its most basic level
the purpose of government
is
do good and avoid evil
it's the same thing that we do in our
own lives
these other questions about freedom
equality justice
economics
they play a role in that too but the
basic thing is do good and avoid evil
and you can't do any of that you can't
have any conversation about liberty or
equality or justice if you don't have
some conception of the good and when
you've got satanists coming in to
elementary schools at literal actual
satanists coming into elementary schools
to recruit little kids and your
political philosophy can't allow you to
say anything against that can't allow
you to stop that then your political
philosophy sucks and doesn't make any
sense
and is not only completely out of step
with the american and western tradition
it simply
cannot work
speaking of
the devil
hillary clinton hillary clinton is in
the news
because hillary clinton
could make
a 2024
comeback
that at least according to doug shone
and andrew stein in the wall street
journal
hillary clinton's 2024 election comeback
sub header
joe biden and kamala harris have become
unpopular
it may be time for a change candidate
now i suspect that doug shone
who worked for the clintons i suspect
doug shone is using this phrase change
candidate to be provocative because
hillary clinton has been around
i don't know since saints st petersburg
when they felt it was time for a change
she's been around since oh i don't know
since eve was gazing hungrily up at that
apple in the tree she's been around a
long time okay in politics and so she's
not what one typically thinks of as a
change candidate but she would be a
change candidate if you were to take the
current democrat president and democrat
vice president kick him to the curb and
bring back hillary clinton
it's not so crazy
it's not so crazy her approval ratings i
bet you are significantly higher than
joe biden's and kamala harris's
now that might just be because she's
been out of the public eye
somewhat out of the public eye for five
years
but it's it's hard to do worse
than
joe biden and kamala harris
joe biden is older than hillary hillary
clinton would be the youth candidate
a lot of people voted for hillary
clinton
i know we're told that that the most
people in american history voted for joe
biden i'm a little bit skeptical myself
because they changed all the election
rules
hillary i suspect is as
bad a politician as she is she's a
better politician than kamala harris
by far she's gotten much further in her
political career than kamala harris
hillary clinton is stilted and awful and
inhuman
but then there's kamala harris who is
somehow more so even than hillary
and
the clearest
reason i think to believe that hillary
might mount a comeback
is that doug shone wrote the column
doug shone who worked for the clintons
is this just an accident this column
showed up
is it just
the mere musings of doug shown and
andrew stein i suppose it could be
but that's not usually how things happen
in clinton world
usually the way things happen in clinton
world and politics and especially in
election op-eds in major newspapers
is that a campaign plants them
just to float an idea just to see what
happens
so what do i think of this idea i think
it's great run hillary run
please because then when she loses again
i can play that clip from the wizard of
oz on my
ding dong
it'll be a lot of fun i really think
it's a good idea by the way i'm not just
saying it from self-interest as a
conservative i think it would be good
for the democrat party she probably has
a better chance than joe biden usually
changing up your candidate
midway through is a terrible idea and it
will kill you but joe biden's approval
ratings basically can't be lower he's
got an excuse to leave because he's old
and obviously suffering from senility
and hillary clinton is an institution in
the democrat party it's not as though
she would be in an unknown quantity
she's exactly what people think of when
they think of the democrat establishment
she's basically just a better version of
joe biden
not so crazy speaking of insufferable
liberal democrat women
elizabeth warren
is speaking out
about some of the economic problems that
we've got right now you've probably
noticed this if you've gone to grocery
stores the shelves are empty the prices
are going way way up it's a big problem
why is this well i think it probably has
something to do with the supply chain
issue i think it probably has something
to do with joe biden just
spending money frivolously and causing
inflation i think this probably has
something to do with the insane
draconian lockdown policies that the
democratic party is still pushing
but elizabeth warren says no you know
all the problems really just lie with
the supermarkets
the tool that we have failed to use for
decades now
has been the antitrust laws so that we
get more and more concentration think of
the example right now for example with
grocery stores remember how many grocery
stores there used to be and now what
you've got is a handful of giant chains
and then what happens uh kroger uh their
profits just in the third quarter of
2021
were almost 900 million dollars that was
more than three times what their profits
were in the same time period in 2019 now
if they are able to expand profits not
expand prices expand profits
that's because they have a lot of market
dominance here
if we move in on antitrust law break up
these giant corporations
then we get real competition and then we
get markets that are truly competitive
if the insinuation here is that the
supermarkets are to blame for all of the
supermarket problems that we're facing
rather than say joe biden and the
government policies and the supply chain
and the cove measures then elizabeth
warren is
crazy
but on the broader point on the broader
economic point that it's bad to just
have a few corporations
dominating industries and and it's bad
to have just a few chains taking over
what were formerly more local
smaller institutions
elizabeth warren is completely right i
hate ah
oh my mouth i wanna ah i need to wash
that down i don't like saying that i'll
say well i'll say one more time just to
get the point
elizabeth warren was right
okay
i don't want to have to say that again
i'll try to keep her name out of it the
point is is extremely conservative
and it ties in with what kevin mccarthy
was talking about it ties in with what
ron desantis is talking about ties in
with a lot of what donald trump has
talked about in terms of globalism and
this concentration of power in the hands
of very few woke individuals
i'll take you back to when i was a
little kid and actually just a few weeks
ago i went back there the place that i
used to go grocery shopping when i was a
kid
was generally not the shoprite or the
kroger or the publix
when i was a kid once a week we would
drive down to the bronx to arthur avenue
the italian neighborhood in the bronx
and we would not go to some big
supermarket to buy our food we'd go to a
lot of little tiny shops we'd go to the
baker sometimes we go to multiple bakers
to get different things we'd go to the
sausage store to get the sausage we'd go
to the cheese store they got the best
cheese in the world we'd go to the
prosciutto store get the prosciutto we'd
go to the little cigar shop get the
cigars we'd go to the produce market get
the really good produce and
all of these things
all of these different items that we
would buy were better much better not
even close go to the bread shop get the
fresh bread much better than what you
would get in the supermarket and the
experience of it was much better and you
would get to know the shop owners and i
still am friends with some of these shop
owners i've known them for 15 17 almost
20 years probably
and that's a that's a wonderful
relationship and you look forward to
going shopping and it's a fun experience
and it involves community
and it increases the quality of the
goods very often
do you have that experience when you go
to
your local supermarket
do you look forward to going to your
local supermarket
do you are you friend do you ever have a
cup of coffee with the owner of your
local supermarket probably not
no you dread going you just have to go
you got to pick up the food or whatever
and then you bring it out you get out of
there as quick as you can usually you
don't even interact with a person it's
self-checkout you scan your own cards
until the machine breaks and then some
guy who doesn't even look you in the eye
walks over and he scans a car and just
walks away
no
if something goes wrong at your gigantic
supermarket
what do you do about it
nothing you can't do anything because
there's no responsiveness because giant
distant entities whether it's the
government in washington dc or whether
it's a mega corporation that now
dominates the whole market they are not
responsive to people they're not
responsive to local communities this is
why it is an extremely conservative
point to want to keep more power local
and more widely distributed
power and ownership in the hands of very
very few dominated by a handful of
oligarchs and a ruling class is not
going to be good
for the majority of people
it's not going to be good for the
american way of life
all right
maybe elizabeth warren has a point
ah okay enough of that
speaking of the food business
the ronald mcdonald house in canada
has announced that it will evict all of
its tenants
adults and children over the age of five
who are not vaccinated by the end of
january
the ronald mcdonald house
is a great charity that houses kids and
their families while the kids receive
treatment at local hospitals
the father of a little boy
who is suffering from leukemia
has just responded to his eviction
notice
this is an eviction notice i believe
to
anybody older than five who's not
vaccinated is getting evicted from
ronald mcdonald house so i'm gonna go
talk to people at the counter and see if
it's legitimate like we got this last
night yes
uh it's just pretty disturbing i'm just
wondering if this will just saying that
like everybody's he's not fascinated
he's getting evicted
well we have a grace period to which you
can
get your first dose but essentially as
of january 17th it's a board mandate
from laura
[Music]
so i just want to get this straight so
by the end of the month
my four-year-old boy leukemia is getting
evicted
because we don't have a vaccine
my parents this is if he was six months
old
you'll be in
but yeah because we don't have the
vaccine you're going to
throw us on the snow
with a few weeks notice
like this is some kind of crazy evil
like i have never seen in my life
this is evil this is extremely this is
one of the most evil things i've ever
seen
and there's the woman just following
orders just standing there in her mask
totally blank face i can't see most of
her face because of the stupid mask but
she's saying yes we're going to evict
you
and your
leukemia-ridden little boy
because you won't take the experimental
drug and he and probably because he
won't take the experimental drug
to protect against a virus that poses
very very very little risk to him
even obviously leukemia is going to
greatly increase that risk
but the father has made a decision maybe
the boy's not going to get the shot in
order to
i don't know in consultation with the
doctor because it's not a good idea
because it's an experimental drug
because for whatever reason because they
won't make the
parents
who are already in this incredibly
difficult medical
moment
are now being told sorry you're out on
the street
there's a scene that whitaker chambers
the ex-communist turned conservative
explains in
witness where he's walking down the
street with a fellow communist and
they're talking about how they've got to
improve the lot of the poor masses
and a beggar walks up to them and asks
for money and whitaker chambers
reaches into his pocket to give him a
coin
and the communist next to me says don't
give him any money
don't give it to him
it's hard i know but do not help that
man
it will dull the revolutionary spirit
you can't do it
and he saw the pain on the communist's
face and that whitaker chambers felt
this pain to do not give him money you
shouldn't give him money
it will it's
better it'll be better in the long run
if you don't have any charity
this is what people mean when they say
that the left
cares a lot about humanity but doesn't
care about actual humans
this is the difference between a vague
abstract humanitarianism
that's going to save the world and
improve the world versus charity
which is a good old christian virtue
it's theological virtue and charity is
when you care about your fellow man and
you actually do things to help your
fellow man charity is a lot harder than
humanitarianism
very very different concepts
leftist ideologues hate charity what is
charity
charity is just to use
a clear definition the infused
supernatural virtue by which a person
loves god above all things for his own
sake and loves others for the for god's
sake
charity is this virtue where we
recognize okay i love my god i'm
supposed to love my god with all my
heart and soul and man is made in the
image of god and god tells me to love
others as
as i love myself and i'm made in the
image of god okay
i'm going to love that i'm going to
treat this person
as someone who is bearing the very image
of god
which means that when you come across
that beggar on the street
you were talking to an eternal being
humanitarianism is different
humanitarianism
is
just kind of on the aggregate raising a
lot of people and if you got to kill a
few people in order to do that well
that's just what has to be done if you
need to crack a few omelets crack a few
omelets if you need to crack a few eggs
to make an omelet that's just the way
the recipe works
totally the opposite of charity you see
this in in the l.a times l.a times has
one of the
spookiest headlines i've ever seen
columns reading mocking anti-vaxxer's
covid deaths is ghoulish
yes
but may be
necessary
and the picture is a young woman young
beautiful woman orange county gop figure
who died of kovid
and he says we should mock her death
this is by michael hiltsick not just
some crank
who wrote a letter to the editor this is
a pulitzer prize-winning
columnist
the original headline by the way which
you can still see in the url of the
article is why shouldn't we dance on the
graves of anti-baxters
why shouldn't we
here's what he says he says quote pleas
for civility are a fraud their goal is
to blunt and in feeble criticism and
detract distract from its truthfulness
typically they're the work of hypocrites
it's almost the same argument that the
communist is making to whitaker chambers
don't don't give in
don't give in to those pleas for
civility
don't give in to those pleas for charity
it will blunt the revolutionary spirit
he goes on mockery is not necessarily
the wrong reaction to those who publicly
mocked anti-coveted measures and
encouraged others to follow suit before
they perished of the disease the dangers
of which they belittled
nor is it wrong to deny them our
sympathy and solicitude or to make sure
it's known when their deaths are marked
that they had stood fast against
measures that might have protected
themselves and others from the fate they
succumbed to there may be no other way
to make sure that the lessons of these
teachable moments are heard
i bet this guy michael hilsick i bet he
loves humanity he cares so much about
humanity
i'm
skeptical that he loves a single person
but he definitely loves
humanity
and that's why we need to mock their
deaths
in order because that will make us good
people if we mock the deaths of others
that will make us good people
because
while we'll hurt many many individuals
many many people we
will i guess help human i'm not quite
sure how we see humanity we need a lot
less humanitarianism in our country we
need a lot more charity speaking of
covid policy
dr fauci
and speaking of death by the way dr
fauci has testified he had another fire
exchange with rand paul rand paul has
caught this guy dead to rights time and
time again you'll recall rand paul
called out dr fauci for funding gain of
function research ran dr fauci said i
did not we have never funded gain of
function research you were completely
incorrect senator
and rand paul said what about dr ralph
barrick i have the papers of you funding
this guy and he's the gain of function
expert and he did gain a function and
fauci didn't realize that rand paul had
the receipts and so his eyes go up and
he goes uh no uh we uh dr barrick was
not doing gain of function
which is a complete
demonstrable lie he's one of the world's
leading gain of function experts
and uh and if he was it was fine
so he wasn't doing it but he was doing
it it was fine
so he got him dead to rights and rand
paul keeps doing this to fouchy and lie
after lie after lie from dr fauci keep
getting exposed so now what did fauci do
he went on capitol hill and he cried and
he complained and he said rand paul
you're exposing my lies is gonna leave
me dead
what happens when he gets out and
accuses me of things that are completely
untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life
harassments of my family
and my children without seeing phone
calls because people are lying about me
now you know i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes i can take the
hit
that is exactly what i'm going gonna say
that's the way it goes and you can take
the hit death threats are very bad i
hate death threats no one should make
death threats
every
single
public
person
gets
death threats every single one
lots of people who aren't even all that
private who are
or who who aren't even all that public
who are just sort of semi-public maybe
you've got
5 000 followers on social media or 10
000 followers and so even then it's not
like you're running the
public health apparatus for america it's
not like you're a top politician even
then you're getting death threats rand
paul knows a thing or two about death
threats buddy
let's not forget leftist radicals tried
to shoot rand paul at the congressional
baseball game and then his leftist
neighbor tried to kill him and end up
broken breaking his ribs and sending him
to the hospital for a long time rand
paul is pretty familiar with death
threats dr fauci has had death threats
his whole career he's been in public
since the 1980s
he's not he is not complaining about
this because death threats are something
new
he's he's bringing this up right now
as a last-ditch emotional manipulation
to say if you criticize me you're
committing murder all dr fauci can say
to rand paul right now is you uh
incorrect senator and then rand paul
proves that he's correct and he says
well and then he just moves on and he
just you're incorrect and now the best
thing he's gonna if you keep talking
you're gonna kill me i hate death
threats i think it's really bad no one
should do it if you make death threats
you should be
prosecuted for it's really bad thing to
do
this is not about new death threats
coming into dr fauci this is an
emotional
manipulation
because the guy
has got caught because what he's doing
is deeply unpopular because people are
finally pushing back against him it's
desperate it's insincere it's just as
disingenuous
as what we're seeing from chuck schumer
and all the other democrat politicians
like dr fauci up on capitol hill i'm
michael knowles as the michael knowles
show we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show a new
quinnipiac poll puts joe biden's
approval ratings below those of paul
blart mall cop that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen